it was october 6
2012 and i would have killed for wendy's
frosty
i've been craving that frosty for about
two days but it always seemed
just out of reach see after urgent care
turned into tomorrow after school which
then became we need to go back to urgent
care
now
and finally in the car on the way to the
hospital i realized that unfortunately i
would not be getting that frosty
because that frosty would have
skyrocketed my blood sugar signaling the
beginning of a journey with an illness
known as type 1 diabetes the car seemed
to hold an overwhelming silence that
night but the world outside was loud
everyone outside seemed to be going on
with their everyday lives while my life
seemed to be on pause as i tried to
understand my new reality
i was hungry and upset and tired and i
made that well known by sprawling out in
that back seat and whining just a little
bit
i was only allowed one thing to eat
a green apple not a frosty
a green apple
but honestly
as much as i would have killed for that
frosty that frosty probably would have
killed me
now i'm sure you won't be shocked to
find out that diabetes is expensive
there's my five thousand dollar insulin
pump the 250 dollars a month for
infusion sites for that insulin pump
and some insurances won't even cover the
fifteen hundred dollars every ninety
days
for constant glucose monitoring system
or cgm
on average type 1 diabetics need 3 to 6
vials of insulin a month
each one of those vials costs around 250
that's 750 to 1500 a month for a drug
that is vital for life
a drug that costs only 3.69
to
6.16
to produce
i'm fortunate enough to have insurance
that covers most of these expenses but i
have a lingering fear
that's shared by most young diabetics of
turning 26
of aging off of my parents insurance
i'm only 19 and yet my 26th birthday has
been an ongoing conversation in my house
what are ways i can get insurance
how will i be able to afford my insulin
how can i keep myself
alive
i experienced that delicate system in
which diabetics operate on the night i
dropped and shattered my last vial of
insulin
it was a sunday night and our usual
pharmacy wasn't open
so my mom began to search for a 24-hour
pharmacy near us well my dad attempted
to get a hold of my doctor's office
after hours in order to get my insulin
prescription sent over to whatever
pharmacy we were able to find
i was able to get enough insulin to last
me to my next refill
my parents had the money to pay the 300
for that tiny vial
but the unlucky ones
the diabetics that can't pay
they have to worry about whether or not
they will be able to afford their
insulin every month
sometimes they have to go without paying
sometimes they have to go without their
insulin
this is insulin rationing
it's exactly what it sounds like
it's skipping meals it's skipping doses
it's taking less than you need or using
a more unstable type of insulin just
because it's cheaper
between 2017 and 2019
14
type 1 diabetics were identified as
dying from diabetic ketoacidosis
a deadly complication of high blood
sugar also known as dka
due to insulin rationing
i want to take a moment for them
monique moses
shane boyle
antavia werschmann
jesse luken
alan rivas
micah fisher
megan carter
stephen elford
kayla davis
josh wilkerson
jada lewis
jesemaya sharer
jeremy crawford
and probably so many more but tonight
i want to tell you the story of just one
of them
alex smith
when he turned 26 he could no longer be
covered by his parents insurance
his job however
didn't provide insurance and with the
cheapest insurance plan having a 7 500
deductible he decided just to go
uninsured
his insulin and supplies cost almost
half of his salary
so he resorted to rationing his insulin
less than one month after going off of
his parents insurance
alec died from dka
he instead paid for the price of insulin
with his literal life
but odds are you know about the price of
insulin
adds are you know it is considered one
of the most expensive liquids in the
world
the price of insulin is something you
can at the very least conceptualize
a thousand dollars a month's worth of
insulin that's a new phone
five thousand dollars every four years
for an insulin pump those are some
really nice vacations
these numbers while large aren't foreign
they're bad but not completely
abstract on my arm is my cgm
it has saved my life more times than i
can count
knows my blood sugar every second of
every day
it knows what i need even when i don't
it has the most obnoxious beeping noise
think worse than a fire alarm
for when my blood sugar's low
and when that alarm goes off in the
middle of the night i would kill for it
to have a snooze button
but it doesn't
so i drag myself out of bed drink juice
and deal with that beeping until my
blood sugar comes up
this device saves me because i can't
detect the signs of low blood sugar the
shaking the world feeling fuzzy the
feeling of a body that's no longer mine
when i'm asleep
and if i were to drop too low
i'd cease
and i'd die
now there's a more
subtle notification for when my blood
sugar's high
an obnoxious vibrating
but if i were to spike too high
it's dka
and this device on my arm that's saving
my life
it's considered a luxury
it's considered something that i could
live without
to put my cgm on i first clean and prep
my skin
then i stick an inserter to my skin and
press a button
that releases a needle
that needle punctures the skin and
retracts leaving a wire behind
then i remove the inserter and click a
transmitter in on top
it's a similar process for my pump
clean stick stab
two little puncture wounds
two little scars
my body is covered
in those little scars
each one representing the cgm or pump
site that had been stuck to my body
each one representing the needle poke
that went with it and the wire or
cannula that needle left behind
imagine
years and years and years worth of scars
and the anticipation of all of the years
to come
little pokes over and over and over
again
now imagine those pokes don't go the way
they are supposed to every time
imagine you hit a vein and now blood is
dripping down your leg or you hit a
muscle and it burns
the needle doesn't retract and get stuck
the sticky doesn't stick
now you have to do it all over again
or the tubing gets caught on a door
handle ripping itself out
do it again
the cgm loses signal to it again
even if those things don't happen i
still have to do it again
every three days for my pump site and
every 10 for my cgm
somehow
i've managed to go nine years without
any major incidents
but i know
just how much
i hate experiencing the highs and the
lows but i know that i am one
miscalculation
one cgm or pump failure one misstep one
mistake from paying the ultimate price
i've mentioned dka a few times as a
deadly consequence but i want to walk
you through what that looks like
you are literally dealing with blood
that is toxic
blood that feels like it's on fire blood
that feels too heavy for your body
your body is turning against you again
then organs shut down one by one usually
the kidneys first then the rest to
follow
a domino effect in slow motion
if you were rationing insulin maybe you
could delay this
but you have one more thing to consider
if you take that insulin now you won't
have enough to take when you eat
tomorrow
and that was the way alex smith died
and every other diabetics who diabetic
who's had to make that decision for
themselves
now i have the privilege to pay most of
these tangible prices
but i still experience
the smaller prices
every day
i've talked about some of those physical
scars but i want to talk about
the ones that aren't visible
imagine
running out of class missing part of a
lecture to grab a juice from the fridge
missing out on high carb meals because i
just know that it'll mess with my blood
sugar delaying a workout
because my blood sugar is not in range
even worse stopping in the middle
being in the heat skyrockets my blood
sugar and swimming drops it being sick
makes it do weird things and any
medication they put me on when i'm sick
only makes it worse
i'm spending so much mental energy doing
math calculating
every second of every day from the
literal prices to the prices that i pay
because i miss moments
so many moments look
standing here and trying to describe
these parts of my life is hard
i experience these things on a daily
basis and yet i can't seem to find the
right words to try and describe to all
of you what it's like
the words i do seem to find don't fully
depict the gravity of these situations
what it feels like to be in them
situations that i got one singular day
of education for
one day to account for a lifetime of
managing a chronic illness
now i can tell you the exact cost of
that frosty
99 cents
54 grams of carbohydrates nine units of
insulin and a heck of a headache when my
blood sugar spikes it was a price i
didn't understand 10 years ago it was so
much more than i could have ever guessed
but now i know that every time i eat
food i am paying both the literal and
metaphorical prices of insulin it was a
price i was willing to pay nine years
ago
but now i get it so much more intimately
than i did the first time and some of
these prices like the financial ones are
ones we shouldn't have to pay because we
pay enough prices already
exactly 100 years ago this month
insulin was tested on a human for the
first time
and type 1 diabetes went from being a
death sentence
to treatable
we took giant steps forward and
improving the quality of life with
diabetes
frederick banting the creator of insulin
sold the patent for just one dollar
so that anyone who needed insulin could
have access to it
and
yet diabetics are still losing their
lives to the astronomical cost of
something that we can't live without
the idea of affordable insulin isn't
revolutionary it's 100 years old
every day
myself and millions of diabetics
experience the roller coaster
that is type 1 diabetes
we worry enough about keeping ourselves
alive we shouldn't have to worry about
whether or not we can afford our insulin
because
i want to eat that frosty
and have to worry about only one price
that headache
that's
sometimes worth it
thank you
[Applause]